so inflation is higher than it's been in
generations maybe than it's been ever
depending how you measure it so joe
biden's response he's going to print a
lot more money and send it to the
government of ukraine
today i'm announcing another 800 million
dollars to further augment ukraine's
ability to fight in the east in the
donbass region this package includes
heavy artillery weapons
dozens of howitzers and 144 thousand
rounds of ammunition to go with those
howitzers it also includes more tactical
drones sometimes it will speak softly
and carry a large javelin because we're
sending a lot of those in as well
oh sparrows the stupid churchill stuff
it's not just the guns that we're
sending the treasury secretary announced
today we're sending another half a
billion to pay for the salaries of
workers in the ukrainian government is
that government
should we be doing that but more the
point what happens to all these weapons
that we send to ukraine well according
to cnn we don't know quote the u.s has
few ways to track the weaponry to send
across the borders
so the weapons are disappearing fast
watch
the first shipments of that new more
heavy duty military assistance for
ukraine started arriving in the region
over the weekend but there is already
concern that more equipment may be
needed soon a u.s official said there is
growing concerns about the ammunition
inventory of the ukrainians as it's
expected that heavy ground combat will
be picking up in the coming days in
eastern ukraine now this new round of
800 million dollars worth of security
assistance includes 18 howitzers and 40
000 artillery rounds but a source said
that those could be expended and used in
just a matter of days now the pentagon
has been working trying to address how
to arm the ukrainians faster
so they've beaten you into submission
with moral lectures meanwhile the white
house has sent more than a billion
dollars to ukraine in just the past week
and then today as we told you the
secretary of the treasury announcement
we're saying they're half a billion to
pay the salaries of ukrainian government
workers shouldn't we have an audit of
zelinski's finances first oh shut up
that's russian disinformation girl doug
mcgregor is a former senior adviser of
secretary of defense he joins us tonight
doug thanks so much for coming on so is
there no concern that because we've seen
this so often in the past that weapons
that we send to a war zone might wind up
in the wrong places
well i think there is some concern but
not enough to stop the hemorrhage of
materiel and money into ukraine
we've had terrible problems in the past
with accounting for where weapons and
ammunition go we saw that in southeast
asia we've seen it in iraq and
afghanistan and i think we can say with
some certainty that many of these
weapons will end up in the hands of
people we'd rather never see them in
but that aside if you listen to what
president biden said today he's
conveying the impression that any of
this will change the outcome it will not
what's happening right now in the
donbass is the final annihilation of
what remains of ukraine's best forces
down in the southeastern corner of the
country
they they can't change that remember the
distance from poland to the battlefront
is roughly the same as
the distance between st louis and new
york city they don't have the
infrastructure to train people they
don't have the infrastructure to sustain
the equipment and then they've got to
move it i'm afraid the only thing we're
doing is escalating tensions with russia
and turning western ukraine into a large
target set for russian missiles rockets
and uh air strikes
i i i this is also sad for so many
people mostly the ukrainian civilians
caught in the middle of it are we making
life better for them it seems like we're
fighting to the last ukrainian to me
well we are and and the thing is i i
really think the president and his
supported supporting advisors believe
that somehow or another they're going to
arrive at a negotiating table in the
future where they will be able to
dictate terms to moscow and that's not
going to happen
and if there is no negotiated settlement
then western ukraine just becomes a
firing range anytime they see any
evidence for significant military
equipment show up they'll destroy it
from a distance because the russians
have never been interested in crossing
the upper river they were always
interested in destroying the ukrainian
forces that job's about through
so i think the sad truth of the matter
is that this is a proxy war in which
we're
sending large numbers of ukrainians to
die without any real hope that we'll
attain anything of importance to them
god it's so depressing
and it's especially as you put it that
way as clearly as you do colonel douglas
greger thank you so much for joining us
tonight
so we're mourning as we told you a
moment ago tonight the involuntary
retirement of mike wallace's son
no more lectures on tv
but even as we're doing that we have an
announcement what you're going to see on
this show tomorrow night and we'll tell
you after the break
[Music]
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight